okay well I like to lay in the hammock
in the summer and this is our version of
that hammock so we're having one rope or
perhaps two ropes hanging between two
trees here and the span is an
angle-theta on on each side here and we
want to know what is the tension in this
rope at the midpoint and here right
where it is attached to the tree and
here we already have the Freebody
diagram I just drew this piece of the
rope here that's that's hanging on this
tree here and we made an imaginary card
we we just cut it in the middle which
means gravity is obviously acting on it
it's hanging through and but it does so
with am half here for our half rope we
know that there is a tension here at the
midpoint T mid and up here we have
attention at that end point that goes
under this angle here I just use an
ordinary Cartesian coordinate system
with I had Direction going in the X
direction and J had gone in the Y
direction so all we need to do is we
need to apply Newton's second law and do
an F equals a MN and analysis to figure
out what these tensions are so let's
apply Newton's second law the F equals
MA analysis to figure out what the
tensions are at the midpoint and at the
end over there so we have F equals MA
and we'll have to very carefully
separate the components here let's start
with eye hat we have T mid
- tea end but of course we have only the
projection of tea end so this is T and
sine theta and since this rope is just
hanging either the acceleration is zero
in the J hat direction we have minus M
1/2 G and then plus T end and here we
have the COS theta component and that is
also zero so we see from here pretty
much immediately that T end equals M 1/2
M 1/2 G over cos theta and we can stick
this one here into the I hat equation so
we'll get T mid equals M half cos theta
G sine theta and that's nothing else but
mg over two tangents theta